salut à toutes et à tous bienvenue dans
ce nouvel épisode de notre série
consacrée au virus dans le premier
épisode on expliquer rapidement ce que
c'est comment ça marche et pourquoi
renault doit absolument arrêter la
chasse russes on évoquait aussi quelques
chiffres qui donnent le tournis presque
autant que le cv d'idrissa berkane si
vous ne l'avez pas encore vu la vidéo
donc ça vaut la peine de regarder on
vous attend le lien est ici on laissait
aussi entendre que les virus n'était pas
toujours de sale petit bâtard et qu'il
pouvait jouer un rôle positif et c'est
justement un des aspects qu'on va
aborder aujourd'hui on va parler des
virus qui ne rendent pas malade au
contraire ils guérissent ces virus
étonnant qu'ils s'attaquent à nos
ennemis plutôt qu'à nos cellules ce sont
les bactériophages comment pourquoi
d'ailleurs rien avoir un mais
saviez-vous que richard attenborough le
mec qui jouait john ramon dans jurassic
park était le grand frère de david
attenborough on vous raconte tout ça en
cinq minutes on va peut-être 10
[Musique]
l'histoire des bactériophages est liée à
celle des bactéries et remonte donc à
des milliards d'années bien avant les
dinosaures nous autres les humains nous
les connaissons depuis environ un siècle
en 1896 ernest and kind biologiste
anglais postée en inde s'étonne de voir
que certains patients guérissent
miraculeusement du choléra après avoir
bu de l'eau provenant du gange oui de
l'eau du gange
au de ganges
à l'époque on sait déjà que le choléra
est causée par une bactérie vibrio
cholerae
and kings qui est un petit malin en
déduit que quelque chose dans l'eau du
gange est capable de neutraliser la
bactérie fort oui mais quoi dans les
années qui suivent plusieurs phénomènes
du même type sont observés des colonies
entières de bactéries en culture meurt
dans quelques heures sans que l'on
comprenne pourquoi il faut attendre la
première guerre mondiale pour que le
mystère soit en partie élucidé par le
médecin anglais frédéric thouars tu es
le microbiologiste français félix
d'airelles
commençons par frédéric thouars qui est
généralement reconnu comme le découvreur
des bactériophages voile appelé fred
parce que bon toi c'est pas possible en
1914 fred décide de se lancer dans la
culture d'un virus connu sous le nom de
vaccine aussi appelé variole tfh ce
virus est tellement important qu'il
mérite qu'on lui consacre quelques mois
la vaccine est une variante bovine de la
variole humaine bien qu'il puisse être
assez impressionnante elle est beaucoup
moins dangereuse en 1796 le médecin
anglais edward jenner a montré qu'une
personne infectée par la vaccine
développer une immunité contre la
variole humaine cette découverte a
entraîné la production du premier vaccin
de l'histoire est amené à l'éradication
de la variole en 1981 bref la vaccine
est une superstar est maintenant vous
savez d'où vient le mot vaccin et que ça
a un rapport avec les vaches mais
revenons à nos moutons thouars temps
enfin fred pardon cultive donc la
vaccine qui ne semble se développer une
vie tronquant présence de bactéries
dans ses cultures ils remarquent des
zones où des bactéries murray se
liquéfie fred comprend que quelque chose
de vraiment minuscule contaminé
bactéries et découvre que ce quelque
chose peut se transmettre il est donc le
premier à observer les caractéristiques
essentielles des bactériophages même
s'il n'est pas trop sûr de leur nature
il hésite entre une mini bactéries une
enzyme ou une amibe
malheureusement ces travaux sont plus
ignorer encore que les rapports du giec
passons maintenant au petit félix ignore
tout des travaux de freud félix terre
elle a eu une vie bien remplie il a été
successivement déserteurs en france
chocolatier au canada dit stiller en
amérique du sud chimiste au
nouveau-mexique chasseurs de sauterelles
en afrique et cetera et cetera les soins
pas jaloux idriss mais durant tout ce
temps félix a surtout été un
microbiologiste assidus en 1915 il
rentre à paris où il est chargé
d'étudier une épidémie de dysenterie une
autre maladie causée par des bactéries
qui provoquent de sympathiques diar es
pour ses recherches phoenix n'a d'autre
choix que de récupérer quelques bols de
kaka bien liquide auprès des soldats
malheur il devait se sentir comme un
journaliste de libé à un meeting de m
en cultivant les bactéries issues du cac
à des soldats lui aussi observe parfois
de petites taches ou des bactéries meurt
comme si les bactéries est tombé malade
d'airelles remarque ensuite que ces
tâches ne sont présentes que dans les
cultures issues des cacas prélever juste
avant la guérison des soldats autrement
dit la présence de ces tâches annonce
l'aguerrissement
félix vérifie son hypothèse à l'hôpital
effectivement à chaque fois qu'une
culture de bactéries a présenté des
tâches le malade correspondant aguerris
dans la foulée un mystérieux agent
induit donc la guérison en s'attaquant
bactérie responsable de la maladie d re
elle continue sur sa lancée à démontrent
que ces destructeurs de bactéries sont
des micro organismes qu'ils nomment
bactériophages ce qui signifie mangeurs
de bactéries
aujourd'hui on sait que ces micro
organismes sont en réalité des virus et
ils sont plus communément appelée fage
der elle multiplie ensuite les
expériences il montre notamment que les
phages peuvent muter et détruire des
bactéries sur lesquelles il n'avait
initialement aucun pouvoir et surtout
qu'ils peuvent contaminer de façon
bénéfique l'entourage du malade guérit
en les protégeant de la maladie c'est
ainsi que félix d'airelles à l'idée
lumineuse d'utiliser les phages pour
soigner il suffit de trouver le bon
fages celui qui s'attaquera à la
bactérie causant telle ou telle maladie
la phagothérapie aînés il faut se
rappeler qu'à l'époque plus d'une
décennie avant la découverte de la
pénicilline par alexander fleming les
médicaments à base d'antibiotiques
n'existe pas
face aux nombreuses maladies causées par
des bactéries les humains sont aussi
démuni qu'idrissa berkane devant un
détecteur de mensonges
d'airelles tests d'abord son idée sur
des poules dont les élevages sont
décimés par une mystérieuse maladie
après quelques semaines d'observation il
repère une poule qui ne semble pas être
affectés par la maladie il recueille ses
fientes puis la relâche volontairement
dans la basse cour en misant sur l'idée
que cette poule scène est porteuse d'un
bactériophages qu'elle va bénéfiquement
contaminés le résultat ne se fait pas
attendre les poules guérissent
miraculeusement au fur et à mesure que
son bactériophages ces peuples il fait
alors une tournée triomphale des
élevages en distribuant d'eiffage en
veux tu en voilà
félix passe ensuite aux humains pour
démontrer l'innocuité de son procédé au
personnel de l'hôpital il avale une dose
100 fois supérieures à celles destinées
aux patients le lendemain des reines se
porte comme un charme alors on teste son
remettre sur les patients et ça marche
en 24 heures les malades sont remis sur
pied la phagothérapie est un succès
total les laboratoires produisent des
flacons de phage à l'éffigie de phoenix
qui devient célèbre point d'inspirer des
livres et des films d'ailleurs netflix
proposera bientôt une mini-série en 287
épisode avec omar sy dans le rôle de
félix terrell et selena gomez dont celui
de thouars tu
malgré cela le scepticisme demeure de
mise dans la communauté scientifique et
les pénicillines de fleming est en plus
simple à manipuler et industrialisés que
les phages d'airelles la phagothérapie
tombe peu à peu dans l'oubli comme ryan
phillippe et billy crawford
sauf dans l'ex bloc de l'est où les
bactériophages continue d'être étudiée
aujourd'hui et où l'on peut en acheter
en pharmacie sans ordonnance
si la phagothérapie est un peu tombé
dans les oubliettes les chercheurs ont
continué à étudier les phages le premier
fage fait observer en 1950 seulement au
microscope électronique
voici à quoi ça ressemble d'ailleurs on
avait oublié de vous montrer la
recherche sur les phages a permis de
grandes avancées en virologie bien sûr
mais aussi en génétique en embryologie
et même en cancérologie le prix nobel
1969 de médecine a récompensé les
recherches menées sur les interactions
entre hôtes eiffage et les phages sont
aujourd'hui utilisés en biologie
moléculaire pour transporter et inséré
de l'adn dans les bactéries par ou pour
stocker et multiplier des morceaux de la
dn destiné à être séquencés qui plus est
depuis plusieurs années la phagothérapie
revient à la mode comme le jeans au
dessus du nombril à force de muter les
bactéries deviennent de plus en plus
résistantes aux antibiotiques
en parallèle on découvre de moins en
moins de nouveaux antibiotiques
efficaces résultat les antibiotiques
soigne de moins en moins bien l oms
considère que ce problème pourrait
devenir la première cause de mortalité
que monde d'ici 2050 les phages pourrait
prendre le relais des antibios ils sont
efficaces et mieux encore plus vite que
les bactéries bref on entendra
certainement parler de fages dans les
décennies à venir
ici s'achève cet épisode pour en savoir
plus vous trouverez plein de liens et
d'infos dans la description la prochaine
fois on parlera d'autre virus sympa si
vous avez aimé cet épisode le partage
est plus qu'appréciée et abonnez-vous si
ce n'est pas déjà fait ah merci aussi
pour vos retours et commentaires
encourageants à bientôt
[Musique]